- Well you posted this photo,
on your Instagram, what's going on here?
- So that's Helen Hunt,
and that is Zac Efron with the photobomb,
in the corner. Twelve year old Zachy.
I went to a program
called CSSSA at Calarts,
here in California when I was fifteen.
Zac and I were two of the
youngest people who went and
Helen Hunt was my acting teacher,
and Zac was in my core acting group and
it was like his first
time away from home and
it was my first time away from home and
it was like this amazing
summer where Helen Hunt,
taught me like Joan of Arc
monologues like it was amazing.
- What is your life!?
- What is my life!? Horses, Helen Hunt
(applause)
- That's an amazing thing.
- Zac made it way younger than I did,
so he was a big huge star before
Two Broke Girls ever premiered, but.
- I did notice he had a
shirt on in that picture,
which is rare.
- It's just rare, but yeah.
- But you know what Zac,
you're working hard for it, just show it.
- Yes, you look great honey. Show it off!
- That's amazing though
that your acting coach,
that's insane to me.
- I know, I haven't actually
got to run into her,
she's one of the people
I would've loved to,
over the years, actually get to be like
"Actually you were my
teacher and you were amazing"
but I've never gotten to,
- Wow!
- I haven't run into
her at anything to like,
- Oh my gosh!
- tell her, but she was
wonderful and I learned so much,
obviously. It was super cool.